last season I thought I'd seen America's
worst hotels it's like being in Danny
DeVito's house but I was wrong this
looks like a [__] prison this season
gets much holy [__] much I'm 16 there a
ghost in it
worse why would I want to stay in here
La
dances once again I'm staying in
America's worst hotels like a mosaic of
seeing so you don't have to how would
you describe the owners borderline
sociopath Hotel owner jail definitely
smells of a business that's run by
Stoners I've been running my ass off for
three [__] days it's like dumber and
dumber and dumbest you're a [__]
disgrace Fu off it's all coming up bur
the building down this season on Hotel
Hell tonight I check into a New Mexico
hotel where the guests are driven Away
by the owner who thinks you share I'm
like an audio Mirage if I do a share
tune you're going to think you're here
and
share
[Music]
you way I've got to find a way to save a
sinking hotel with Dreadful
entertainment I would pay you 100 bucks
not to sink awful food it's like the cat
sh over my plane and a general manager
who can't be trusted does the general
manager badmouth the owner behind her
back yes what an untrustworthy
backstabbing son of a [__] you
are
[Music]
the 14 bedroom maon de msia is a small
boutique hotel located in the Border
Town of Las Cruses New Mexico it should
be be a wonderful Southwestern Oasis but
the few guests that visit the hotel are
in for an unpleasant surprise owner KY
shinsky purchased the former bed and
breakfast in 2006 and completely
remodeled it putting her own distinctive
taste and style into every aspect from
the food to the Furnishings to me it's
very European it's very Tuscan in nature
maybe that's the Venetian plaster but I
didn't really pick a style as much as I
just picked out things that I liked and
one thing Kelly likes a lot is beige the
bedrooms are beige with beige and a
little beige the walls are freaky it
looks like it's trying to be marble but
it's plastic I do not believe the
customer is always right definitely not
a place that I would feel comfortable
staying sometimes they're wrong I that
well pregnant she wanted to make sure it
was well you know the more you cook it
the less waver will have how's that
chicken porm tender salad going Callie
made the menu we only serve Tuscan food
I don't even know if Call's ever been to
Italy 86 for
told you guys forever that was an awful
recipe but it may not be the bad food or
the decor that's keeping guest
away my mother was a bartender and she
would have me sing to people and they
paid attention to me and they liked me I
live for Applause Kelly tried to make it
as a professional singer but when her
career started she found her own
personal concert venue I bought the
hotel to sing the audience members
really like me a lot unlik an an audio
Mirage you if if I do a share tune
you're going to think you're here and
share if you're not looking at me you
think I am
[Music]
share I find no way I take back those
ones that hurt you and
[Music]
you we get a lot of telephone calls it's
Callie singing tonight well then that
kind of means they
like I think I surprise them quite a bit
cuz they just don't expect it
[Music]
time give me just a second here after
that song I need a little drink too two
months ago Kelly hired local restur Zan
Steinberg as her new general manager
ladies how are we who Che who's checking
in xan's wife Mitsy has been working
with C since the hotel opened in the
beginning my husband xan and Callie's
relationship was very good has it
deteriorated a bunch where are the keys
how can I get anything done if that
bastard won't put [__] back Dan is the
biggest problem here right now and
that's unfortunate because I brought him
on to help me with what I thought the
biggest problem was was we don't have
enough customers some kind of general
manager he is Callie should be fired for
being a poor operator and digging this
thing into a hole with ownership and
management not on the same page the
guests are the ones that suffer how is
everything here we're basically ready to
get our food to go cuz we waited so long
okay let me take care of that Cali
believes that the customers have a place
in her hotel but Callie's at the tippy
top of that pyramid I do not enjoy going
up to tables and having something wrong
at every [__] table I go to I don't
like it at
all hotel bookings have fallen to an
all-time low and for much of the year
not one of the 14 bedrooms has a guest
in if things don't change fast the hotel
will be forced to close someone needs to
be able to tell me what it is I'm doing
wrong everything that I have is tied up
into the hotel
I need Gordon's help
badly my first time in New Mexico I'm in
Las crues in the Southwest desert and
look at it I mean absolutely stunning on
the way to the maon de Mia now this is a
small boutique hotel possibly the
perfect getaway you have arrived at your
destination you're kidding me I mean
this is a joke you've arrived and look
yeah I'm going to [__] sound turn
around when possible this is crazy
doesn't make sense you have arrived at
your destination is that it there turn
around you'd think they have a decent
sign on there wouldn't you looks like a
prison
finally hello hello welcome to my S msia
good to see you so whose favorite color
is beige well Cali was The Decorator cie
is the cie is the owner the owner right
this is our cleaning agreement if you
could read and sign it please cleaning
agreement yes yes just so you don't I'm
not coming for a job or you don't damage
our property this is a damage your
property yes the own is very concerned
about the Venetian
plaster the owner is very concerned
plaster and she wants me to sign a
waiver yes sir said I won't damage it
yes sir does everyone have to sign these
everyone yes why would I sign a waiver
I'm not sure why you'd want to sign a
waiver no sir I'm not going to sign that
by the way welcome good to see you what
a first impression I don't believe that
there needs to be a waiver I just do
what I'm told you put all these things
on there it doesn't look like New Mexico
to me it sure doesn't maybe Italian uh
well I have two rests in Italy and my
rests haven't got pictures of New Mexico
bloody hell let's go up to the room do I
have to sign a waiver to walk on the
carpet No Sir look that was not me looks
like someone's pooped on my wall oh you
got a little fireplace a fireplace
that's exactly what you need in the
middle of a [__] desert do you have
any alternate rooms I'd love to move if
it was Les beige all the rooms are going
to be the same oh [__] well thank you
I'm going to P you going to leave me
alone on my own in my room do I need to
sign a waiver no sir no nice to meet you
by the way nice to meet you too Gordon
thank
you this room is so Bland it looks more
like an airport hotel than a fun weekend
getaway in the heart of New Mexico I
can't wait to meet the woman behind this
hello hi welcome to the sign Gordon and
call Callie good to see you good to see
you too um I thought that you'd be
wearing beige with a lady that's in love
with beige everywhere I do like beige my
favorite color is beige but I think
beige goes with a lot of things I didn't
sign the waiver sending that message out
to every customer coming in here is not
a good sign to begin with while it's
$7.50 a squ foot to replace the Venetian
plaster so it can be a lot if someone
does some damage why don't you um show
me around I would love to show you
[Music]
around this is the main dining room how
many St you go here 89 what you have a
stair it's a stage where I perform oh
wow amazing and percussionist guitarist
no I actually right now I sing to tracks
so you have like a backing track and you
sing over there yes yes I do okay wow
wow wow and this is the bar this is the
bar over there we have another stage I
usually sing in here on Fridays and okay
and who else performs here no one else
no wow wow wow and then through here
seriously what's all that [__] in the
pool well that's from the pool cleaner
who was supposed to be here this morning
it's a little bit late is it busy the
pool no it's not very SAR to people use
mind you I suppose it's like going for a
swim in a prison Jesus Christ what's on
the back there that was for
entertainment my God three stages I sing
everywhere in the hotel I love to sing
period three stages I hope there's no
stage in the
kitchen hello Hi how are you good Sarah
Sarah Ang Sarah nice to see you likewise
where you from I'm from New Mexico oh
nice I am excellent is the cuisine uh
New Mexican there's nothing here that's
new Mexican at all no this is all very U
confusing I'm looking forward to tasting
the food later anyway whatever it is
let's catch up with the B shall we nice
to meet you nice to meet you too I like
to cook Southwestern Cuisine it's like I
don't know why we have Tuscan
food as the owner in your mind what's
wrong with the place well we don't have
enough customers and you've had it now
since 2006 how much did it cost 1.2
million wow and that's what I purchased
it for how much did you spend converting
it another
1.2 2 and a half million bloody how I
shut down for 14 months to remodel it 14
month shutd down it wasn't supposed to
be 14 months it was supposed to be four
it turned it into 14 months and a
million 2 to do it and the contractor
was indicted platy how I've gone through
a lot of stuff with this hotel it's like
I'm starting to think maybe the problem
is I'm just too trusting how long can
you continue putting money in I've got
maybe 60 70 $70,000 left so for the next
6 months m
yeah unless unless we unless it kicks up
um listen I'm uh I'm here to help and
I'm sorry it's been this difficult thank
you I'm glad to see I'm I'm really glad
you're
here I've just arrived at maon De msia
and I'm confused by this hotel who put
all these things on there it doesn't
look like New Mexico to me it sure
doesn't I met Cal Theona and she told me
she's desperate for this place to
succeed I'm really glad you're
here so I'm Keen to meet the general
manager and see why he's letting this
place fail on his watch now you're the
general manager I'm the general manager
um how long have you been working in
hotels hotels would be 9 weeks said I'd
never been in a hotel but I'd always
been in restaurants full service
restaurants how does a restaurant
manager become qualified to be a general
manager of a hotel when you've never
worked in a hotel before it's not that
complicated take care of the guest check
it's not that complicated I don't
believe it is I can do the work it's not
that hard there's only like six seven
things I need to learn what are the
major problems major problem is Cali is
the owner she's the major problem major
problem she is too controlling and my
hands are being tied if you're not being
allowed to do the job you came in to do
why are you
here I'm here cuz I'm emotionally
invested in the place how the [__] can
you be invested when you been here weeks
well my wife's been here all these years
anytime somebody calls in sick the first
person they call is mity we've always
thought it's a gold mine we just can't
figure out why we can't get people in
the seats the only way for missan to be
successful is for Cal to back out what
are these things here uh the vinyl we're
uh disgusting in fact can we take this
off do you mind instant looks better
right you not need to be a general
manager to make that decision do you no
is there a server or we're going to
bring a server over for you now and his
or her name uh mitti MIT oh it's your
wife yes how are you good how are you
let's order first shall we okay and then
we'll have a chat all right what would
you like we are in New Mexico aren't we
yes we are in Las our is Taste of
Tuscany yes why wouldn't you just go for
a modern stunning delicious Mexican
Cuisine I guess it's because she thinks
there's enough of them it's
crazy uh the petta looks good okay the
chicken picata that sounds interesting
okay the lamb lollipops wow it's not
cheap is it $23 for the lamb lollipops
thank you my D bloody hell I got
the I know good food thank you so much
no problem our food is really good to be
forewarned it's not to catch my plate B
normally goes with uh Tomatoes yes and
this is olives and anchovies popular
dish um no it's like vomit that
pacy dear dear word got out that I'm in
town and the restaurant is starting to
fill up with customers pleas I feel
sorry for all of them wow here we go my
$23 lollipops been the longest member St
here what do you think is wrong with
this place um I think K's reputation is
it that bad she's rude she's rude mhm
she's brass she's short she's not
flexible I think you get the picture
thank you my D blimy not what I'd call a
loyal Workforce or fat $23
Dreadful tough as
[__] do you like lamb I love lamb he's
tough as anything seems a little tough
and perhaps a little rare a little tough
what is going on I know you haven't got
much Hotel experience but isn't this
your Forte Restaurant yeah yes bloody H
I'm finished with that thank you I mean
Dreadful absolutely can tell that is the
Lamb Frozen the lamb comes Frozen and we
thought of course you find out where
it's from
yes lamb lollipops no
go so far nothing I've tasted has even a
remote connection to the area nothing
local nothing authentic nothing new
Mexican New Zealand New Zealand lamb mhm
wow that part's right that part's right
our chicken is um picata is
non-traditional thank you for visiting
us here at Mand msia my name is Callie
I'm going to do just a little music for
you this afternoon Little Rock number
from Shar love
her
[Music]
you
way I'll take back those words that it
hurt you and you stay by if I could
reach the
star i' give them all to
you then you know me love me like you
used to do and maybe I turn back time hi
ladies how are we nice to see you I'm so
sorry about the noise and it's not in
the kitchen yes a little bit
much I'm not too sure what's more scary
the food or the singing what would you
say
I don't know they compliment each
other by a fake bunch of
[Music]
[Applause]
GRA and thanks for joining us here is
that normal yes that's not just because
I'm here no she is not share I am sorry
I I love this thing that's probably why
I bought this
place I've got to to get away from this
horrendous
singing we haven't met yet have we say
again sir we haven't met yet have we no
sir I'm David David what' you do yes sir
I'm a pantry Pantry yes sir are you
trained David oh it's trained a little
bit sir I've been around sir and where's
your love of food coming from where
where did you where my father your
father dad's a chef no sir my dad was a
nurse but he loved to eat wow walking in
another calamari with the rim you L I
have the second calari selling right now
ma'am just two seconds it's already bre
is Fri I'm not Fred right now sir that's
already cooked yes sir so when was it
cooked oh actually we get in a box sir
we get from a fish company sir
completely Frozen just touch that oh yes
sir it feels like rubber I I don't eat
the fish here sir how come you know this
and you're still doing it my opinion
doesn't matter in this restaurant cuz
you know it's bad and yet you just
against you will do
it
life wow I hope tonight's guest can
remain as positive as David has if you
can sign this here for me it's just a
cleaning agreement a what a cleaning
agreement just in case you do throw red
wine on our walls does that happen it
has happened actually unfortunately the
guests checking in are getting the same
terrible welcome that I did if I could
please have you re good evening ladies
welcome nice to see you both thank you
I'd like to apologize about the waiver
all right well you you got to do o oh oh
not throwing red wine on the walls you
sign a cleaning agreement yeah so what
does that mean like do the check off
list when you come in and then do the
check off list when you exit in the
morning is there any other breakfast
other than coffee in the morning no
ma'am there's no breakfast is there room
service or anything no ma'am you're
lucky you're not hearing the singing I'm
going to head to the bar for a quiet
after dinner drink any more singing and
I feel like my head might
explode okay what is going on Customs
are having dinner and all of a sudden
she breaks into this music totally
unexpected oh totally yeah she just sits
there and absolutely in it yeah and what
the [__] seriously I've seen enough for
one day just you going to have to lay
that down somewhere where is she going
now she just going to sing no not in
here sir you kidding me I thought these
guests in here were the lucky ones I did
too the same numbers exact same she's a
nut child exact same word yes my name is
Cal for those of you who don't know I do
a little entertaining here got any share
fans in the audience oh my
God hey thank you with dinner service
and the terrible Coke concert finally
over it's time to get the chef and the
management together and find out what on
Earth is going on
[Music]
here let's get one thing absolute
certain it is not a taste of Tuscany
it's not funny it's a cluster
F so are you are you are you proud of
this no I told why doing it CU I'm not
allowed to change anything oh my God I
feel like there is many pricing issues
here there are definitely change that
have to happen you're amazing it's just
total horseshit it's just total
horseshit you know it's just like are
you lying no we work within the
constraints and I'm allowed to work
immedately this should all been should
been all constraints my ass you have
done nothing since you came in here but
talk about me behind my back try to set
me up to fail every [__] day why do I
want to make you look I don't know I
wish the hell I did know but I've got
several people we can line up and we'll
tell them exactly what you said to them
I imagine we will you know I can hear
the same thing about you you know I'll
leave and the only thing you'll say The
Parting words not to me is I hope he
hangs himself know how horrible is that
when I'm doing an event here well I tell
you how horrible it is about as horrible
as when somebody hires all new people
and tells each of every one of them that
she's a [__] to work for you can't work
ear but hang in there because in 6
months I'll be running this place and
she'll be gone I mean literally right
out of the box right out of the box so
there he goes that's what it all goes
back to yeah because that's when I found
out what an untrustworthy backstabbing
son of a [__] you
are I got to worry about my back
continuously with you what this major
miracle old man that was supposed to
come in here and double and triple this
business when there's been no change
whatsoever none it was I allowed to make
any changes like direct dramatic you
wanted you wanted to hire new people
which you did course you told each and
every one of them that they shouldn't
work for me God's sake is that true
there was the impression given that Cali
would no longer be here whenever we were
brought she owns the place why were you
suggesting that she's not going to be
here after Sierra
starts I don't recall that hor [__] wow
it just wasn't her it wasn't her it was
Annie it was everybody God does the
general manager badmouth the owner
behind her back
yes of course she doesn't trust you if
you're going to bad M behind your back
if you were the owner what would you do
I would fire that person that bad mouth
me you're
fired
I think I'm leaving I was just
fired Now call I'm sorry you've already
failed and you need a Fall Guy okay you
got me you run it you step up to the
plate good luck I'm leaving too I'm out
of here I feel betrayed and if the [__]
thinks I'm going to stay she's nuts you
know I don't mind Callie yelling at me
it's fine she finally got it off her
[__] chest but she doesn't trust
anybody you know everybody's burned her
in her history I don't know I didn't
burn
her it felt good to fire him because
it's been a cancer here at the hotel now
the tumor's been cut out and we're going
to be in better shape Zan's just been
fired and the level of animosity and the
friction between those two is
extraordinary but the question is what
happens
next I had a rough night's sleep with
that Bloody share tune going round and
round my head I'm hoping I can wash that
tune out of my brain with a quick swim
and that's not all I'd like to forget my
first day at Mason was crazy within hour
of my arrival the general manager was
fired what an untrustworthy backstabbing
son of a [__] you are and I had to
endure torture by Coke I really didn't
mean to H
you today has got to be better than
yesterday let's hope the pool guy
came the pool is still
dirty what the hell is that what a joke
I mean what a badly utilized space I
mean
you think of a hotel anywhere in New
Mexico God one thing is an asset this
this pool I mean this space could be the
best thing about this hotel yeah it's
just abused dirty not even a towel out
here
so going a [__] with some in there that
is
disgusting breakfast so no morning swim
for me but at least I can enjoy a good
breakfast to start the
day God that's all they've got to offer
how depressing is that this is crazy
I've got to find some breakfast I'm
starving and cold coffee isn't going to
do it but I've heard there's an amazing
farmers market in town so I'm going to
quickly check it
[Music]
out what lovely little place I've heard
David from Mason's kitchen runs a food
truck here in his spare time no deep
fried calamari I hope I saw the line I
thought wow what are you serving got
cadas best in New Mexico okay brilliant
I have a little food truck with a buddy
of mine Chris a little taste of New
Mexico this is one of our favorites
right here the cucumber lime that's
perfect
little but 100° outside that's perfect
right yeah tast great my goodness W
that's delicious so what's in the quad
cheese GRE chili and cheese here you are
my friend thank
you that was delicious yeah now David
that's better than anything I've eaten
it in the hotel you know that yes sir
delicious thank you sir the food truck
is my creative Outlet it's a place for
me to at least express my ideas without
having any borders well done I'll see
you later good job delicious enjoy the
food guys thank
you this town is stunning full of charm
and local color it's such a shame the
hotel reflects none of that I've got to
find a way to get Cali to embrace New
Mexico and make the most of what her
hotel has to offer how you feeling hope
okay I think it's important for you to
understand the bigger picture okay yeah
can you come with me please thank you
hopefully what I have planned will open
Call's
[Music]
Eyes Kelly this is some of your guests
I'd like you to share your experiences
why don't we start off with you first
please first impressions are important
to me and the the very first thing I had
to do was sign a cleaning waiver and it
it just it makes the assumption that I'm
not going to be clean that assumption
was it was just a tough first impression
yes a valid point waivers of for bunge
jumps at your perel the whole thing for
me wasn't to make you think that I
didn't think that you were clean it was
I had someone come in and throw red wine
all over the Venetian plaster and I
thought that I should charge them for
that but you're punishing every other
guest one guest and it's not right you
know you can't penalize future business
on the back of one
idiot so it appears that there's no
thought into what the customer is going
to experience for instance um the first
thing on a hot day you want to go into
the pool um and we looked out to the
pool and and it and it's right now it's
the same way it's got um a lot of leaves
and it's dirty so maybe it's not open
but how can it not be open yes a valid
point Madam please we were in the lounge
for dinner and when you were singing we
couldn't have a conversation it's just
not appropriate for an upscale intimate
fine dining experience I feel like
you're very focused on the performance
but you're not really focused on your
guests very interesting so anything that
goes wrong with the restaurant when
you're singing you're too busy singing
and not caring about your guests I would
pay you 100 bucks not to
sing as long as you are focused on your
singing career and not on your
restaurant and hotel career my wife and
I won't be
back I don't agree I have quite a bit of
people that come here to hear me sing
guest feedback is critical it's about
turning that negativity into something
positive now I'd like to introduce you
to a very special lady nuu mamid she is
the features director and the senior
correspondent for travel and Leisure
magazine NE um give us little insight to
your stay please one of the things that
we look at is whether a hotel has a
sense of place whether it's maximizing
the value that that beautiful setting
that it's in has you mentioned the pool
that's one great example of a moment
where you have a potential great asset
here that is being underutilized and
it's kind of underwhelming there's a
reason why Hotel schools exist so it's
not a hobby it's a business there is one
question I'd like to ask you all would
you come back to stay in this hotel
again please raise your
hands no one um thank you to you all
your feedback has been absolutely
pivotal appreciate it I was sending a
message that I didn't realize I was
sending and didn't want to send I want
people to come here I want them to feel
welcomed are you starting to understand
I am you are I am you're worry about the
wrong things the
biggest issue you have is understanding
who's number one the guests have to be
number one not C that's that's that's
the bottom line if you can change that
this place has every chance of becoming
a big
success can you
change will you help me I I will help
you but You' got to start listening I
can do
it I
can I hope
so coming up that's awesome the biggest
transformation in the history of Hotel
Hell and a shocking twist where's all my
[__] it's been a tough week at M on the
msia but I believe Cali is finally
committed to putting a guest first I can
do it I can so overnight my design team
have pulled off an incredible
transformation which I can't wait to
share with c and her staff are we ready
yes sir please turn around wow a
stunning sign wow now when you drive by
it tells you what we are the S of hotel
and restaurant gorgeous right very
beautiful now everybody that goes by is
not going to wonder huh wonder whose
nice house that is are you ready to see
inside I'm ready because this you're
going to absolutely love
morning everybody look how beautiful how
are we oh we cool welcome to your new
hotel breakfast buffet wow remember what
breakfast used to be like we had cold
coffee now you have a very traditional
stunning breakfast buffet that will be
serving crisp white linens not those
horrible plastic cloths and that's not
all I reached out and got an amazing
local talented breakfast Chef let me
introduce you
to meet David our breakfast chef wow
David hi David hey David that's a
wonderful thing I I feel great right now
I'm loving the recipes and I'm I'm
really excited to be in the kitchen
right now Kelly yes sir I think that's a
much better way of using that stage than
a kellyoke
evening let's go welcome to you
suweet very cool wow get in there very
cool wow
wow very very cool so we've Incorporated
some of the local colors and brought
them in to this Boutique Hotel Kelly how
you feeling amazed Room 205 is is an
amazing amazing room it it's a New
Mexico fi and I know it's not bait but
you don't mind D no no not at all I
think it's gorgeous I do the walls are
still beautiful and yet we have all this
color and and and it goes so well with
the area that we're in I've added color
but there's something I've taken away
there are no more waivers for your guest
to sign is that good with you Kelly
good it's awesome the front desk no
longer has waivers and the new rooms are
colorful they fit with exactly where we
are in this historic district I am very
proud to show people the new rooms I got
one very small thing to show you you
ready we are this you're going to
love oh it's out
here oh my God oh my
God that's amazing that's awesome now
that's what I call a pool yes it is
remember there was leaves and crap
everywhere now welcome to one of the
hippiest one of the coolest pools
anywhere in New Mexico that is the Oasis
in the middle of the Des gone is That
Hideous fence and replaced it with new
turve and pool furniture to die
for beautiful it is it is people will
just want to come and hang out here now
bam bam this is awesome the pool
absolutely beautiful never seen anything
like it if we don't have pool parties
now then something's wrong this is your
fantastic Cabana area gun is the stage
if you want to sing Kelly do it in the
shower I have a margarita
Carlos I'll be serving a lot of drinks
out here uh I'm hoping the business is
going to absolutely kick off with this
wonderful
pull now that you have a stunning
outside area
let me introduce you to your new
poolside menu wow wow poolside so you
start off with a lovely refreshing
tomato gaspacho beautifully marinated
seasoned lovely with extra virgin olive
or fish tacos as well oh I'm going to
eat all that yes and delicious fruit
kebabs oh this is great wonderful fresh
fruit mango orange lime coconut and
seasoned with those wonderful Green
Local chilies A Taste of New Mexico not
Tuscany Kelly outstanding the tomato
gaspacho is is is magnificent I'm very
proud to cook this food it makes sense
and it goes with New Mexico I think it's
excellent have a good look at the menu
get used to it cuz we're going to be
pushing it big time see you in a minute
this makeover is the biggest I've done
in any of the hotels I've visited
there's over
$150,000 worth of upgrades and I've
never been happier with the improvements
it's exactly what the guests need if I
was Kelly I'd be over the
moon green chilies peons everything that
New Mexico is about we have it on the
menu we have the guaca we have the salsa
what I do with the five cases of
hamburger bnes that I just brought
[Music]
in and and even more hey what we want to
spend an hour putting things away every
night and then bring them out every
morning this is what Ramy gave the hotel
labor labor labor
labor who do I hire to do that this is a
lot of work I can't I can't
I deal with
it you got to go
oh my God there's things that I'm
concerned about the pool is outstanding
it's scary to me because I've got a
pretty big job ahead of me now and the
Linens major pain in the
ass so many things that I'm going to
have to do that right now I you know I'm
really like freaking out over these and
what what I'm going to do is raise
prices Callie is a little overwhelmed
right now I do believe she likes the
fact that it's more new Mexican Jesus
got on but Call's C where's all my
[__] where's all my [__] what does that
mean the all the other stuff that you
took away what stuff tell me and oh the
tapestries oh I know you took down all
the grapes which it was covering a
pretty big hole in that wall let show me
show me what we what we wi what we
winging
about is that what you're worried about
is a plastic bunch of grapes to hide
this where somebody hit it with a table
we can get your grapes back and you can
stick plastic grapes back on the wall
let me show you something for two
seconds I want to show you something
really
important just have a look at that out
there how beautiful is that gge it's
exactly what you guest need and want let
me show you
something oh oh there it is look at that
amazing stuff there and I look at this
pile of [__] in here and you're starting
to create a fuss forgetting that this
hotel is about the guest and you start
putting the teen on edge because you
want plastic grapes here's what I'm
going to do for you in 15 minutes I will
clear all that furniture okay and I'll
put it back in my van and this [__] here
I'll put back in
there let me show you
something oh oh there it is I look at
that amazing stuff there and I look at
this pile of [__] in here and you're
starting to create a fuss here's what
I'm going to do for you in 15 minutes I
will clear all that furniture okay and
I'll put it back in my van and this [__]
here I'll put back in
there
I am I am ex should we get for should we
get in there and look for your grapes no
I am more grateful than you can possibly
you have a very bizarre way of showing
it that's all thank you
Kelly sometimes what I say with the best
intentions is taken with the worst and
to be aware of that is very good because
that just means that I'm going to be
able to start thinking the thought all
the way through before it comes out of
my mouth
I'm glad Call's grateful but I am
worried as soon as I leave she'll be
back to her old ways plastic grapes
won't kill her business but if she
carries on singing that might you
mustn't take this the wrong way and I
hope you don't but I grew up with a dad
that was constantly moving our family in
and out of working Men's Clubs bars and
singing every [__] weekend seeing him
ruin his life trying to be someone who
was never going to
be the other night I watched you move
from here to here oh
Christ you shouldn't be doing this in
here I think there's a level of class
about you the way you hold yourself the
way you dress the way you you appear I
don't want to see you
being laughed
at I really don't know how to to uh to
react but obviously
[Music]
um
every time you're singing you're not I
totally agree with you right
now it needs to be
run okay that makes sense to me K okay
thank
you I think K's ready for a fresh start
so invited lots of new guests and a
local band for maison's first ever pool
party hi table 4 four five 15 15
how are we are you good having fun
gorgeous place
right enjoy the PO party crowd are
loving all the changes the fish tacos
are yummy awesome they're loving the
food guys yes keep it going yes you know
my first job when I was 18 pot wash
starters running but I wasn't running to
glamorous pools like you're about to run
to and the new guests are loving the
colorful rooms oh wow this is beautiful
this is beautiful
another that's comp I think this will
work people will like this idea it's
really NE to have something like this in
Mones cuz there's something like this we
don't have to leave town we're here
vacation I think Kell's heart is in the
right place but she has a lot to learn
about running her hotel I'd like to
introduce you to a very special man Mr
Jeff Mayhem nice to meet you likewise
how are you doing K do wonderful now
this man has a wealth of experience
spanning nearly three decades of running
some of the most prestigious and
luxurious boutique hotels in Jeff's a
former inkeeper of the year he's not
just good he's one of the best he knows
this business inside out after all he
does something so well that he's in
Keeper of the year I want my guest to
get the experience that his guests get
I'm going to leave you two alone spend
some valuable time okay great we look
forward to working with her thank you so
let's talk okay now cie clearly she
can't turn back time but she can insist
on this place having a bright future on
one condition she stays off that Bloody
microphone and makes her guess the stars
are not bloody singing can she do it
that's the million dooll
question coming up I finally put
Callie's singing career on
[Applause]
[Music]
Ice it's the end of a long week at maand
De msia I'm really happy with the
changes at the hotel but it could still
all fall apart If instead of stepping up
as general manager Kelly steps back onto
the stage it's time for me to say
goodbye if you have that little urge
that you start getting the Tremors and
you feel a need for the mic I want you
to run into the freezer stay there 2
seconds I put your microphone in a block
of ice now this will give you two or
three hours to defrost which will give
you a chance to understand that the
guests are the stars I understand that I
want you to seize these changes and run
this stunning Boutique Hotel I will
thank thank you I found out from Gordon
I don't have a singing career and that's
okay I this is my
career If I Could Turn Back Time can't
get that Bloody song out of my
[Music]
mind since my visit bookings at Mand de
msia have surged welcome to Mand de msia
to you for dinner the new guests are
enjoying the pool and the new menus it's
delicious pry impressing I didn't even
know this place was here and Kelly is
learning how to be a proper general
manager I appreciate you coming you're
welcome thank you I really am very
grateful a man knows what he's doing
thank God for Gordon
[Music]
Ramsey tonight on Hotel Hell I'm in Long
View Washington trying to save one of
the Pacific Northwest precious gems
which has been shamefully neglected oh
my gosh the wealthy Hotel owner has a
drinking problem that is spiring out of
control want to see the hotel owner
jailed phip was arrested for DUI
50 devoted staff are desperate to save
their jobs we care about this place and
we care about you but a lot of us feel
like you don't give a damn about us
you're calling your staff Liars i' call
them [__] Liars can I get this hotel
back on the wagon before it's too
[Music]
late
Long View Washington voted one of
America's prettiest towns is home to
Pacific Northwest jeel the Monte cell
Hotel built in 1923 this historic
building is currently celebrating its
90th anniversary but unlike cheese and
good wine some things do not get better
with age
oh my
gosh I'm Philip loving fos and I'm the
owner of the mon solo Hotel I've wanted
to own the hotel since I was 8 years old
my mother worked here when I was very
young and I remember all the cocktail
waitresses and how beautiful they were
and wanted to be a part of it some might
say the story of how Philip loving fost
obtained the hotel is almost too good to
be true others might call it a fairy
tale Philip was a partender here he fell
in love with the owner Annabelle Jewel I
was in my early 30s when Annabelle and I
first started going together and she was
in her
mid-60s they were married and when
Annabelle passed away all of her assets
were given to Phillip he inherited the
Monella Hotel all
pretty with his inheritance Philip has
been living the good life with his
girlfriend and general manager Ginger
who's also 30 years a senior TJ but
despite the owner's fabulous wealth the
staff are underpaid I still make minimum
wage and I've been here 12 years yay
we're getting in the
dark Philip flaunts his wealth in front
of us don't flaunt it in our face when
we're all wondering do we put gas in the
car or do we buy groceries this is
[__] unreal he's probably got
$150,000 worth of diamonds on his right
arm 10 karat diamond ring on his left
finger he walked through the kitchen one
day and and somebody broke a glass and
he said oh do I lose a stone I mean
really how [__] arrogant I want to
say [__]
you while Philip and ginger have been
enjoying their wealth the hotel has been
terribly neglected Sy Burns oh my gosh
seriously that is so gross I'll go all
the way down the hall around the corner
inside the beautiful Historic monacell
Hotel there are only four Suites and
then there are countless rooms stuffed
with Philip and ginger crap instead of
guests with only four guest bedrooms
available in the main Hotel Motel most
guests unwittingly given rooms in the
so-called North Wing which is a
character less 1960 shoe box Motel Next
Door I was hoping to stay in the hotel
don't even feel like staying here now
and having been ignored for years the
hotel is not generating any new business
with a rapidly dwindling client base
where's Mary she's not here with us this
once glamorous hotel has major problems
but Philip's problem may be the biggest
it is no big secret that Phillip drinks
Philip will come in here drunk good job
good job in front of all the staff and
it's just an embarrassing
mess I think that Philip could die if he
doesn't stop
drinking it scares me the day before I
arrived in Long View things reach crisis
point I was pulled over and they charged
me with a
DUI I was uh placed under arrest they
booked me in the K County jail and
yesterday morning I was released
it's an unfortunate situation thank you
you guys have a good night you too this
hotel its staff and the community
deserve better Phil talked about closing
it if Gordon isn't able to save this
place for us um 50 people will be out of
jobs and Phil will be on his yacht in
Seattle drunk hey NASA this place is a
gem that needs to be preserved it's the
heart of Long
View this town needs the monello
[Music]
gorgeous that place is massive look at
all those rooms for guests finally
somewhere nice to stay I feel sorry for
the crappy Motel Next Door I'm amazed
that place is still open right next to a
big hotel like that my
[Music]
god wow look at those beautiful cars
must be a car show on oh no somebody
having a laugh Hotel h
lad's nine who the [__] can't spell
part-time housekeeper I can't do
anything worse to advertise on the
outside of your
hotel morning good morning and first
name is Vanessa Vanessa nice to see
Gordon I see you're having a classic car
show today no those all belong to our
owner philli no stal they do they belong
to the owner yes they do what's with the
plate there's like Hotel Hell on one of
the plates yes but you did that for me
oh I'm not sure if he did it for you or
for him wow uh Jeff daggy employer of
the month 2010 you know it's 2013 I do
yes are the staff that bad there hasn't
been a more recent employee of the month
last I heard actually he was in jail
holy crap we have so many great
employees it's ridiculous that we're not
recognized more than we are here's your
card and here is your room code you're
in room 220 uh will you show me the way
or oh sure if you'd like shall we please
do follow on me I'll got that we're
going outside yes okay just across here
so you have to go out to get back up
again
yes m220 right
here um but this is not the Hotel this
is our North wi motel and why in the
[__] would I want to stay in there all
we have available to rent in the hotel
are four
Suites I'd rather stay in there next
door okay than in this dump I'm sorry
people want to stay in the hotel
they don't want to stay in the Cracker
Box driving up here I didn't expect to
be put in a motel no I understand and
I'm I am
sorry all right it's just right over
here thank you you're welcome ly how
That sofa's Hideous who would use a
[__] Brown sofa like that oh my God
it gets worse in here this bed is this
auntie uh no the rooms are furnished
completely with stuff from Philip and
Ginger's home oh dear there a mattress
from their house yes you bring a
mattress from your house into your hotel
I wouldn't they charge $250 a night for
that mattress I don't even know what to
say about it when they get new stuff
they bring old stuff here there's some
storage rooms that are full of old
furniture where the storage places where
the jeez it's like a sweet just full of
crb it's like a dumping ground there's
more too wow you are kidding me I'm not
oh my God look at this I wish I was
kidding you insane it's like a hoarder
it's just junk everywhere I don't
understand found a hotel owner that
would dump half their [__] in hotel
rooms and not rent them out Gordon was
pretty appalled at the state of the
storage rooms how much crap there was in
there it's just a big [__] waste I
appreciate it you're very welome thank
you wow this place is so disappointing
the biggest highlight so far as the
drive up the minute you step inside it's
just bizarre I can't wait to meet the
owner and find out what the hell is
going on in his
head
I've just arrived at the Monte Cella
Hotel in Long View Washington and I'm
shocked to discover that there are only
four rooms for guest in this Grand Place
While others are been used for storage
oh my God it's like a hoarder it's just
junk everywhere I've got to meet the
owner and the general manager and figure
out what else is wrong with this place
Hello nice to see you very nice to see
you welcome to the mon thank you what a
gorgeous place from the outside good
thank you how are you good so you're
Ginger yes this is my significant other
hello there you go is that true that's
true wow look at that bling have a quick
look it looks like a Super Bowl
ring too heavy for me um I thought there
was a car Fair here so someone told me
they're yours they're mine amazing let's
go to the
lounge did you always want to own a
hotel ever since I was a little kid I
wanted to own this hotel serious and
what's the building worth now between
probably 3 and 5 million it's
extraordinary I inherited it all the
estate yes and if you don't mind me ask
him what was that the tune of 10 million
wow is the hotel making money or losing
money it's losing money I've been
carrying it how much you losing 30 do
35,000 a month losing this last 400
Grand a year yeah that's insane there's
lots of sleepless nights for me how are
we losing so much money been taking
advantage of I know that who's taking
advantage the kitchen staff for sure
they wait and leave the clock to think
you're going to get paid for hours that
you're not working they can't do that to
you I I think Gordon's going to have
difficulties with my employees I don't
see them as team players at all if this
place was taken away what would it mean
to you devastating it would be
equivalent to a death jeez I started
here in 1973 this has been a huge part
of my life wow well let's give me an
Insight let me tell you um Ginger nice
to see you dnie very nice likewise thank
you you thank you excellent welcome
again thank you so much it's terrible to
hear that Philip and ginger are been
taken advantage of by their staff when
they clearly care so much I really hope
I can help them sort their employees out
oh hello good evening how are you I'm
fine I'm Debbie Debbie Gord nice to see
you I have a table for you right over
here now how long have you been here I
have been here 12 years wow seriously 12
years yes um right what would you
recommend I
recommend our crab and arti choke dip
okay let's go for one of those all right
Phillips triple Tower yes what's that
it's a three- tier Tower of three
different appetizers and here's his name
big enough on the menu there obviously
suffering from small man's syndrome
let's go for that and then the button at
ravioli let's try that all right thanks
de nice to see
you so the appetizers first please okay
I'm feeling really nervous about cooking
for Gordon they're all [__] froze
together most of of food is prepackaged
or canned or frozen because Ginger and
Philip are running this place like real
misers they uh Pinch A Penny on every
corner this is our crab and artichoke
dip it's served with deep fried peita
bread and um is it fresh crab or canned
frozen chili and crab frozen chili and
crab
correct Jesus Christ [__] snot
dip I mean it's like a dish ready for
one of Philip's girlfriends no teeth oh
God it's got the sour taste to it I
don't know what it is no Jesus ni you're
welcome he felt it tasted sour it always
got that taste to me I don't like
it you are kidding me this is the tower
this is the tower this is the tower oh
my God holy Macos
so no I but it's like something you
should have in your [__] Garden not
in your restaurant they shrimp are they
fresh or are they frozen they're frozen
they're frozen
[Music]
damn [__]
disgusting and what's in here they're
teriyaki beef
tips Jesus that sauce is hideous and
that's just
tough beef tips it's like beef chew and
that middle one's another portion of
snot dip I'll skip that well
unfortunately for the chef he doesn't
get to dictate his own menu
what the chef doesn't like his own menu
he does not let's move on shall we my
God
careful so Philips dictating the menu I
suppose if his staff can't be trusted to
clock in and out they can't be trusted
to choose the
food feedback on that um the meat is too
tough the sauce tastes weird he can tell
it's not
homemade is this ramsy's uhuh and it is
I me it's too t he getting a full
picture and that's just what I want
right feel very good about it I am very
disappointed with Dan's food was
horrible I just hope that Gordon sees
the problems with the staff
ravioli I'm dreading bringing this dish
out to him right now the butternut
ravioli thank you who made the raviolis
I don't know the name of the
manufacturer manufacturer correct so the
ravies aren't even made either they are
not made here oh Jesus they're
[Music]
packaged that's Dreadful like a l full
of sugar every
time oh dear thank you D wow frozen crab
frozen shrimp prepackaged ravioli it's
more like eating a badly run old folks
home than a decent restaurant obviously
from a package we all knew that one was
coming I think there's a better way that
the our kitchen can function than it's
functioning right now I see just blatant
neglect um tell me about Phillip's
management style well when he's sober I
get along with him just
fine when he's drinking I avoid him at
all costs does he drink a lot on S he
does on a scal want to 10 how bad is he
drinking now a 10 a 10 this week he was
arrested for what
DUI you are [__] kidding me I'm not
kidding oh my my God I want to see the
hotel owner jailed jailed he was kept
overnight in jail bloody hell why would
he not tell me that when it just
happened hours ago Philip's in denial he
doesn't take responsibility for his
drinking problem and I felt Gordon
needed to know [__] the truth is
starting to come
out um why don't you ask the chef to
come out of the dining room I'd like to
meet him and bring philli and ginger as
well
thank
you he would like to see you all in the
dining
room I'm I'm lost of words Chef that was
Dreadful I don't think anything was
fresh it takes extra time to do things
homemade uh yeah naturally we're on a
time restraint what ask how many hours
they get in a week or whatever and they
got to scrape for my my prep cook gets
20 hours a week that's not enough time
to make fresh food is that why all the
food's Frozen I mean I get cut carrots
or cut celery in the bag I get the
boiled eggs in a bag done peeled you buy
in boiled eggs
yes I played the safe card and purchased
most of it prepared you played the safe
card we can't even boil a [__] egg in
here philli if you care about quality
you need to pay people to prep fresh
food not buy it in there were times uh
through January February where I'd have
12 16 hours a week a week yeah how' you
survive 3 hours a
day not very well but do you have a
family yes I do Dan seven kids this is
insane you can't run this hotel like a
miser if I sold [__] three of those
cars and put it into the kitchen budget
to function for the next 12 months the
chefs can do their job and speaking of
cars why don't you tell me about this
[Music]
I'm at the montiell hotel in Long View
Washington oh my God the monteo hotel
owner jailed jailed and I've just
discovered that the hotel owner has a
drinking problem so bad that just one
day before I arrived he was arrested for
drunk driving can I have a word with the
owner please
yes what is going on truthfully I don't
know
G have you had a drink today
no yes you
have your
staff tell me that you have a drinking
problem
no and yet you've just been busted for
DUI Ginger does your boyfriend have a
drinking problem he does like his
libations pissed off that you couldn't
even say hey Gordon can I have a word
Gordon I fully intended on having a
conversation flashed all over the
newspaper I'm aware of that who owns
this place me so when are you going to
step up I'm here Gordon I'm engaged if
you can't be honest with
yourself you're
[Music]
[__] the facts are starting to become
clear the problem here isn't the staff
it's the owner you have um room service
you do not no room service in a hotel
this size that's not the only unpleasant
surprise guests check in and just like
me they think they're going to get a
room in a historic gem but instead
they're placed in the motel disgusting
it is disgusting I don't think I could
shower in this wonder if we can ask for
a different room this is
awful and F Alfredo's ready and during
dinner service most of the guests are
over the age of 17 there clearly hasn't
been any Buzz about this place in
decades yes sir it's not prime R should
be a little moist out shouldn't it well
I can go I can go and check and see if
there's another inut back there Dan yeah
do we have another in cut a moist one
please be juicy it is okay FL we do this
no why all of a sudden is he
involved cuz I'm here I'm sorry
strawberry
de I can't believe Phillip is put on a
show for me well if you want to know the
truth about a drinker ask the
bartender Grant that's what is going on
tonight it's like a comedy of ARs here
you're welcome does Philip normally ex
night no no what does Philip normally do
at the hotel he does drink quite a bit
well and on average a day how many
drinks would you make a day during the
day sometimes 4: or 5 and then it jumps
into the evening it could come up to uh
78 Jesus I had him cut off of a new one
oh wow wow no wonder things are on the
slide with Philip drinking that much
I've got to get him to tell me the truth
this monstrous hotel has been running
rudderless there's no one at the HM and
you're pretending all of a sudden I'm
busy I'm exper time lifting because I'm
here I I I just no it's not because
you're here we don't normally do this
stuff this is what I normally do you're
calling your staff Liars I would say so
if they say that I'm not out here
helping them every time I walk in this
building I would call them [__]
Liars come on be [__] honest with me
do you think I can just wave a [__]
magic wand no when the place is running
to the
[Music]
ground with dinner service over you say
I'm going to get philli and his staff
together so I can finally get to the
truth is that normal what I witnessed
tonight is Philip always here no does
Philip always expedite the [__] hot
plate no no we need somebody to expedite
we're underst stabbed and if we get busy
then we can't give good service and
those people will not come back a person
can't shortcut like that of this place
the business been strangled it's been
strangled by the owner why are we
pretending I'm doing a good job of
pretending then this is what I do every
time that you come in here this is what
you do I did not run food down to your
bar for the last couple nights let's
talk about the elephant in the room
shall
we when Philip's drinking he behaves one
or two different ways either he's jovial
and likes to giggle and have a good time
or if finances are in aars we hear about
how much everything costs you and you
were going to close the doors it's
stressful it it's not easy to come to
work with someone threatening us all the
time that the doors are going to be
closed please don't look at me like that
philli because you do do this to us
that's [__] you need toar the truth
you have told us over over and over
again that you're just going to shut I
may I may have said that twice twice to
come in here regularly and say I'm going
to close the doors if we keep lying
about [__] and we keep covering up [__]
and whatever then he ain't going to
[__] help us and here we go like this
like we've been going for seven [__]
years he's he's been known to walk
behind the bar and fix himself drinks
after the staff Cuts him off pH
yes is that
true that I don't know
about that I don't don't know about I've
gone behind the bar and made my own
drinks yes so you're blacked out you're
that inated that you've got no [__]
idea that you're that far gone if he
goes behind the bar take the drink away
from him he cannot go back why is he in
there in the first place why is he even
in that bar in the first place why is
have to do that to me it's hypocritical
you put out memos saying that we can't
drink in the bar it's hypocritical
Phillip and we care about this place and
we care about you but a lot of us feel
like you don't give a damn about us why
are you coming in here to put your your
employees in a bad uncomfortable
situation if it was up to me I'd say
Philip you can't drink in here because
if something happens to you take out a
family of four they're coming after me
and my family and I don't have any money
to to afford a lawyer keep me out of
jail for the rest of my
life I'm at the montiell hotel in Long
View Washington where the staff are
confronting the owner about his drinking
problem if it was up to me I'd say
Philip you can't drink in here because
if something happens to you take out a
family of before they're coming after me
and my family and I don't have any money
to to afford a lawyer to keep me out of
jail for the rest of my
life they are telling you the truth cuz
they freaking care unfortunately you're
not telling the truth and that's why
this business is struggling this ship is
on a collision
course can I show you something I think
you should all see come with
[Music]
me
I think everybody's forgotten what it's
like for guests to stay in this hotel D
April how much is this room $250 a night
Friday and Saturday is $180 the rest of
the week let me show you what $250 gets
you at the Monte cell turn the lights
out you see that this black light shows
up bodily
fluids that's exactly what you're see
disgusting I wouldn't want to lay on
that bed where these mattresses come
from Philip the house in Arizona your
house yes wow those two two holes there
that's cigarette holes uhoh
Burns watch out every don't touch there
oh she I was totally grossed out when I
seen that bed it was sickening
$250 to sleep in Phil oh my God Philip
Seaman right there is everywhere does
that make anybody else feel sick yeah
cuz right now I am [__] disgusted by
this foul polluted
bed I felt dirty I'm a clean person was
disgusting I don't know why you're
running a hotel you're just ripping
people off if you don't care for the
customers and you don't care for your
staff who do you care
for I care about my staff the first
thing you said to me when I arrived here
philli what's the problem staff they had
bleeding the clock huh no
way that's what you told me I've got
half it Wroten down at home where I put
at least 100 hour free in here we will
come in an hour 2 hours early not punch
in and then we will work late to get
what we need to get done you have an
estate to the tune of 10 [__] million
do and a chef that puts 100 hours in for
nothing or is he lying he's not lying
he's here all the time I'm surprised you
guys are here I'm the only earner for my
family and I make 500 bucks every two
weeks this is [__] crazy
[Music]
and you rock up here with a plate with
Hotel help what the [__] is going
on these guys are your bread and butter
your [__] backbone but they're
terrified to tell you the truth you
can't keep on cutting corners and
humiliating them because they're the
problem the fact they it's not busy look
within it starts from the [__] top
amen yeah could you just excuse me and
leave me here on my own with Philip
thank you
now can you [__] your man up I don't
have all the answers Gordon I'm trying
give me one [__] answer give me
something you're abusing your
staff what kind of message that it send
to them when you fill the car part with
classic cars and they're [__]
struggling J it's fair do I think it's
fair no no do they deserve
better of course why you doing it I
don't have an answer for that I don't
know why I'm doing
that get out F me leave me alone get the
[__] out of
[Music]
here that was rough sleeping in a tub is
bloody uncomfortable but it certainly
beats sleeping on that filthy mattress
[Music]
the staff have been as honest as they
can be but they're all afraid of losing
their jobs both you come with me please
it's time Philip and ginger heard from
the people who aren't afraid to tell
them the truth he good morning everybody
morning
morning thank you so much for
coming your guest I'm going to give you
some honest
feedback that room was dirty it looked
like an animal was killed and drugg out
the room me this stain goes down the
hall there's no thought to the guest
experience at all wow you feel like you
threw your money down the dream I was so
disappointed to know that I couldn't
stay in a piece of history and got sent
over to a motel I was shocked at the
decor that I saw it was just hideous it
was brutal to hear that many guest
complain about a one night experience in
the hotel it actually scares you away
when you see the Marquee that says
Thursday lat's night and hiring
part-time housekeeper you don't want to
advertise that you're short on
housekeeping whose stupid idea was it to
advertise for a part-time housekeeper I
guess it's my idea I'll take the
responsibility thank
you can I ask you one question would you
come back and stay here please raise
your hands no never
never I appreciate your honesty thank
you thanks you heard what the guest had
to say yeah I did do me a favor spend a
couple of minutes here looking at what
you've inherited and ask yourself do you
really want it enough do you really care
enough yes I do care I don't think you
[Music]
do owner Philip and general manager
Ginger have just found out what the
guests really think about the montiell
hotel would you come back and stay here
no
never I think Ginger has finally r
realized how much Philip's drinking is
hurting the
hotel and now she's asked to speak to me
alone it's been hard because it's deep
well his alcoholism is very deep I can
say it's been hard and I've reached out
to my children and they've all talked to
him but it hasn't been any good and it's
getting worse the stress on my end has
been where's he at is he driving is he
going to kill somebody is he going to
kill himself
I just wish You' told me the truth
that's all I am a private person and
this has been very hard and it's hard to
see someone destroy themselves I don't
even think he realizes how bad it is
it's been a very heavy F not
me he's very old it's a terrible
disease he's an old man and you're
suffering the
[Music]
consequences he needs help and that's
the truth I'm going to persuade you to
get treatment God would you do that for
me I will do that I want this place to
work okay thank
you and I'm
[Music]
sorry I'm going to need the staff's help
to get through to Phillip come through
guys maybe together we can break through
his
denial I'm going to get Phillip in now
and I need you to get behind agreeing
that he needs help
no it's hard but you're part of this
change and you stand up for what you
feel is right the staff needs him to
show us that he's willing to make a
change I think he needs to become honest
with
himself this hotel is at breaking
point and you need
help is there anyone else in this room
that thinks that Philip needs help with
his addiction please raise their
hand
they all here because each and every one
of them care not just about the hotel
but about you Ginger you know how bad
the drinking problem is yes I do I pour
out bottles I empty him out down the
sink because I love him and I hate to
see him destroy himself and that's what
it's been like it's been very
hard if you could see it through our
eyes it's like night and day during the
day just you're amazing Phillip you talk
to us with so much respect and stuff
like that and as soon as you start
drinking you can see that huge
difference come over you it's like the
black cloud We Really Care About You
Phillip I mean we're afraid for you
because your Rock Bottom isn't going to
be like most because you have the money
to your way out you have the money to do
what you do your Rock Bottom is going to
be very serious it's either going to
kill you or kill somebody else I don't
want to see you die and I don't want to
see you and trouble and hurt
somebody you're very important you're
worth getting clean you're so worth it
okay philli will you get
help you cannot keep on hiding this I
don't know what you want me to say
Gordon what about what you want to say
I'm not saying
anything we're
done if the entire staff can't get
through to Philip maybe speaking to him
alone will help change his mind he's got
to get help otherwise this place doesn't
stand a
chance when are you going to snap inside
and say
[__] I'm hitting rock bottom I've been
in this position for the past several
years I'm sorry to hear that don't get
upset huh don't get
upset it's all part of it so what you
want to do
[Music]
Phil are you ready to get help
please I promise you I'm definitely
going for my family for my staff I'm
going into treatment appreciate that
come here it's time some things in life
are more important than business and I'm
glad Philip has realized he has to put
his health first and sort out his
problems coming up welcome to the new
and improved montiell
[Music]
Hotel changes in the air at the Montell
Hotel so overnight my design team gave
the hotel the makeover it truly
deserves good morning morning welcome to
the new and improved montiell
Hotel before we go inside I want you to
notice
something that Dreadful Motel
sign has
disappeared when people want to make a
booking you can offer them a choice of
the modern Annex or the historic hotel
and that will be a lot easier because
I've opened up four new Suites for
guests doubling the number of rooms in
this Historic Hotel wow oh
yes let's go guys come do it I have
butterflies I am so excited to walk in
that hotel come jumping ladies boy
welcome to new site isn't it beautiful
wow I love it oh my
God this is a beautiful room it should
be used for guests not
storage never my wife oldest dreams did
I think our storage unit could end up
looking like this are you ready to see
the bedroom that's so cool I don't I
don't even have words gone is all that
secondhand furniture replaced by a
comfortable bed with luxurious Linens
now we have something to be proud of I
mean the place is absolutely
gorgeous stunning new furniture
beautiful Linens and beds for all your
sweets very classy his mind-blowing what
Gordon has done is just phenomenal what
do you think
I think that this is a room that I can
be proud to send my guests to Oh My
Goodness Me wonderful of course they're
never going to want to leave no now I'd
like to show you my
room oh my God this is amazing for me
the stunning interior matches the
Majestic exterior now you look on the
outside you think this is exactly the
kind of fill you want inside have a
quick look at the bedroom chandelier
this one you're going to love oh boy oh
and the bed as you know with two
mattresses full of stains now look that
beautiful bed that's what you call a
proper king-sized bed oh wow it was our
best room before and now it's the best
room in town it's beautiful come through
guys the potential here is phenomenal
it's the heart of the town again and
something to be proud
of oh excuse me welcome to monell
stunning new room
service wow oh how can a hotel of this
standard not have a small Dynamic room
service menu increases the turnover my
average check but more importantly guess
they actually longer to know the food's
that good in the room as
well now get yourselves a plate and
start tasting wow this is so good those
are rotten potatoes I know yeah there's
nothing like fresh salmon that food was
amazing I can't recall the last time I
tasted food so fres I think it's going
to be a real bonus enjoy the rest of the
food we got a big big night ahead of us
it's a really nice menu I think it's
going to bring the revenue higher this
is exactly exactly what we needed this
is Sensational
MH
beond it's not just room service I
reinvented the menu for the restaurant 2
using the best local ingredients I'm
confident the combination of great food
and great rooms will encourage a whole
new generation to come here that's
getting medium in there it needs about
another minute or two then we'll pump
that one out okay the difference between
the Frozen and the food we're getting
now night and day there it's it's
undescribable for The Taste the
presentation it's awesome keep cooking
we're fresh ingredients I willome okay
and remember this the day a kitchen
can't be bothered to boil a [__] egg
yeah get out of there okay you're better
than that yes sir good job thank you
yeah well done thank you are you
checking in yes oh can I get your name
uh s ah you're staying in one of our new
suets I can't wait for people to see
these rooms oh wow and I'm ecstatic I'm
going to have to send so many less
guests out to the motel this is what I
had hoped
for although the guests are delighted
with the changes it looks like Chef Dan
has a problem quick word what's wrong Oh
no you're
[Music]
leaving the montiel's relaunch is going
brilliantly nice to see you lordon you
okay but Chef Dan has just pulled me
aside no let's go here take a seat what
9 years clean this over wow that's
phenomenal well done so I would love to
be a sponsor Philip sponsor if he would
have me be a sponsor once he gets out
he's going to need somebody by his side
that's an amazing
commitment it's a real big
responsibility to be Phil sponsor but
it's one I'm I'm willing to take on get
our owner on the right track yeah good
job thank
you it's going to be a challenging
Journey for Phillip but with all the
support he has from Ginger and his staff
I'm hoping you'll be able to stay away
from alcohol so mhm when you get out of
treatment you're going to need a sponsor
somebody take your meetings so 9 years
clean this over if you want I
offer thank you joh all right I
appreciate that sound good it does now
with new life breathe into the Montell
it's time for me to go both of you take
care of yourselves okay good luck thank
you sir ter say good luck oh dear next
time I see you give me a change man oh
yes I will one more thing before I go
what makes this place very special is
not just it's a historic building in its
90th year for me it's the staff so just
so you don't forget it here we are a new
plaque wonderful and the employers of
the month this month are the entire
staff and you need to do more than just
recognize how good they are you need to
pay them properly y Ramsey did a
wonderful job the hotel is flowing in
the right direction
cuz I do have a good crew to turn the
ship back around and make it Thrive and
I'm going to seek help for my drinking
thank you
Gordon wow what a
place I really hope Philip keeps his
promises time will
tell since my visit to the Montella
hotel bookings have gone up this is
really
nice
and with all the new Revenue coming in
the staff are working with a new sense
of enthusiasm because Philip is finally
paying them properly for all the hours
they've put in Gordon I want to thank
you for what you did you saved 50
people's jobs and their livelihoods and
their
families and philli is booked into a
treatment program which starts next week
all I can say is for Gordon is God bless
you and thank
you